et en numéro 313 de Monsieur jean Bizet
madame la ministre de l'Égalité des
territoires et du Logement merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Madame la miss mes chers
collègues madame la ministre
permettez-moi d'attirer votre attention
sur les préoccupations
exprimées par plusieurs élus de mon
département à propos de la difficulté
pour mobiliser des crédits en faveur de
la modernisation de l'habitat dans les
zones rurales depuis la modification des
priorités de l'Agence nationale de
l'habitat en 2010 sont désormais
privilégiés en milieu rural la lutte
contre la précarité énergétique des
propriétés occupants et pour l'ensemble
du territoire la lutte contre l'habitat
indigne dans le parc de locatif
la mobilisation du parc vacant et
l'amélioration du parc locatif ne sont
donc plus traitée que marginalement
obtenir un gain énergétique dans les
logements et bien entendu un objectif
louable sur le principe et j'y souscris
mais dans les faits atteindre le seuil
des 25% pour pouvoir réellement
bénéficier des aides s'avère
particulièrement délicat dans la plupart
des cas et en particulier pour des
projets modestes la réforme du régime
des aides de Lana s'avère défavorable
seuls les dossiers qui présentent des
montants de travaux importants sont
avantagés par le nouveau régime dans un
département rural tel que celui de la
Manche il est souvent difficile de
pouvoir atteindre ce niveau
d'investissement d'où un sentiment de
frustration est de déception de la part
des propriétaires et bien évidemment des
élus
cette décision est lourde de
conséquences puisqu'elle rend difficile
la réalisation d'une part supprime ainsi
l'outil privilégié des collectivités
locales pour lutter contre la vacance en
secteur aggloméré elle vient en
contradiction avec le discours général
des pouvoirs publics qui incite les élus
locaux et leur partenaires à cibler la
reconquête des espaces urbains délaissés
au cœur des villes et des Bours plutôt
que de poursuivre la construction et
l'urbanisation en péril en périphérie
des villes j'avoue que je souscris
totalement à cet objectif et nous avons
au cœur de nos bourreaux dans toutes les
régions de France se gravent problème
cette orientation est ainsi reprise et
inscrite dans la plupart des scottes je
m'occupe du scotch du Pays de la Baie du
Mont-Saint-Michel et j'y souscrit par
particulièrement et s'impose en matière
donc de conclusion par conséquent au
plan locaux d'urbanisme d'où une
certaine incompréhension
et irrationalité et donc qui débouche
sur le découragement des élus je vous
demande donc au moment où une
augmentation des crédits destinés à la
NA est envisagée qu'elle mesure le
gouvernement entendre prendre pour
préserver une politique de rénovation de
l'habitat plus particulièrement dans les
zones rurales
merci madame la ministre
monsieur le sénateur ce n'est pas la
première fois que l'on attire ici mon
attention sur la situation du logement
en zone rurale et vous pouvez être
certain de ma grande conscience que la
situation du logement en zone rurale si
elle est très différente de la situation
dans les zones tendues n'en est pas
moins plus difficile notamment en ce qui
concerne la situation des centres bourds
dans un certain nombre de villes petites
ou moyenne vous l'avez évoqué mais
également dans la dégradation du
patrimoine
le patrimoine en situation de vétusté
thermique et plus important dans les
zones rurales que dans les zones
urbaines dans un certain nombre de cas
puisque une partie d'entre eux est plus
ancien sur ces territoires l'enjeu est
donc de mobiliser le parc privé et de
travailler à son amélioration les
propriétaires
occupants éligibles aux aides de Lana
vous avez évoqué les questions des aides
de Lana sont plus représentées en milieu
rural 38% loge dans un situation de
propriétaire occupant contre 27% pour
l'ensemble des propriétaire de Maison de
la métropole ce sont donc des
destinataires importants de ce programme
vous avez indiqué que l'objectif en
pourcentage d'efficacité énergétique
gagner par l'isolation et difficile à
atteindre je tiens à vous dire que ça
n'est pas le cas puisque l'expérience
montre sur le programme habite mieux qui
visait tout particulièrement des ménages
en grande précarité énergétique et avec
des faibles au niveau de ressources je
pense tout particulièrement d'ailleurs
aux personnes âgées il est à noter que
ce sont elles qui sont aujourd'hui les
principales victimes de la précarité
énergétique dans notre pays des
propriétés occupants à très faibles
ressources plutôt âgées dans des maisons
individuelles d'une époque où l'on
construisait son se préoccuper des
questions d'isolation et le taux moyen
de d'économie d'énergie réalisée sur ce
programme et de 39% au lieu au-delà bien
sûr donc des 25% exigés je pense que il
faut donc être réaliste et se dire que
si l'on travaille sur l'ensemble des
clés qui permettent la rénovation de ce
patrimoine la clé financière c'est ce
qu'a annoncé le président de la
République avec l'amélioration du
programme de rénovation thermique qui
au-delà des aides classiques
issues du CIDD ou de l'écho PTZ vont se
voir adjoindre une prime d'aide à la
rénovation de 1350 euros cette prime
concernera les deux tiers de la
population française et primes qui
pourra aller jusqu'à 3000 euros pour les
personnes les plus précaires il faut
savoir que ce travail se peut se doubler
d'un travail sur l'amélioration de
l'habitat c'est toutes les dispositifs
qui existent et qui existent poussées
notamment par nombre de collectivités
locales qui permettent et je suis je
partage totalement votre avis sur ce
point de s'attaquer à la rénovation du
patrimoine en sciences entre bourse
souvent délaissés aujourd'hui et qui
provoque donc creuse qui provoque une
situation de d'abandon de certains
petits quartiers des centres bourgs
alors même que se poursuit
l'artificialisation des sols et la
construction
de quartiers or des centres-bois donc il
me semble effectivement très important
pour l'amélioration de la vie de ces
territoires ruraux et de bourruraux que
nous travaillons sur la prise en compte
de ces questions cela sera également le
cas dans le cadre de la future loi
logement et urbanisme que j'aurais
l'occasion de venir présenter ici dans
quelques semaines
merci madame la ministre monsieur Bizet
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je prends acte de vos réponses
et j'attends de voir concrètement sur le
terrain je dirais leur efficacité et je
prends note également de la future loi
que vous nous présenterez dans quelques
semaines au Parlement en ce qui concerne
les propriétaires occupants je vous fais
crédible que c'est plus confortable
financièrement mais il y a une grande
part également de bien dans les
boursuraux qui sont je dirais entre les
mains de propriétaire d'ailleurs et
c'est là où nous avons un énorme
problème parce que la génération qui est
en train de disparaître en quelque sorte
en zone rurale avait théorisé et investi
sur la pierre et nous avons beaucoup de
propriétaires bailleurs qui ont pas mal
entre guillemets de propriété qui sont
totalement laissés à l'abandon parce que
ils ne peuvent pas réaliser une
opération je dirais à peu près équilibré
tout simplement parce que en zone rurale
également le montant des loyers
mais pas je dirais au travers de cet
objectif précarité énergétique qui
encore une fois est un objectif
particulièrement louable mais j'aimerais
vous faire toucher du doigt que cette
orientation n'est pas aussi simple que
cela et les vertueuse louables sur le
papier et les très difficiles à mettre
en place je dirais dans les faits moi je
suis prêt à rencontrer vos services avec
des simulations que nous avons fait
faire par un certain nombre d'organismes
dans le département de la Manche et nous
ne pouvons pas réaliser des opérations
donc
quand je vois que parallèlement les
schémas de cohérence territoriale ça n'a
pas été facile de les mettre en place
parce que la consommation de l'espace
c'était souvent la réponse des mers
ruraux à cette problématique on a réussi
dans un territoire un petit peu
particulier il est vrai qui est le
territoire de l'abbé du
Mont-Saint-Michel a bien faire
comprendre aux élus ruraux que ce
n'était pas la réponse nous y sommes
parvenus à beaucoup de négociations
parallèlement nous avons besoin d'une
réponse de l'État qui nous donne si vous
voulez des satisfactions pour permettre
de mobiliser des crédits pour rénover
ces coeurs de bourre parce que comme
vous l'avez dit derrière également tout
cela il y a une qualité particulière du
patrimoine qui si dans les 10 ou 15 ans
nous ne réalisons pas cela il va
complètement disparaître